now everybody thinks there's a scup
conspiracy theory and this one actually
made it substantially worse X block
searches for Taylor Swift after explicit
AI fakes circulate so long story short
on on Twitter SLX a bunch of extremely
graphic images of Taylor Swift started
emerging yo these pictures were crazy
and and and it never ends CU it take two
seconds to make more but now at a time
when everyone is suggesting that Taylor
Swift is part of a conspiracy
to uh uh rig the Super Bowl so that she
can help the Democrats win in some way
this controversy around AI images
happens which results in one of the
biggest social media Platforms in the
world shutting down your ability to
search for things related to
her this is a media blackout on Taylor
Swift the Twitter X is the news I mean
even even Elon is talking about all
these news Industries news organizations
are collapsing because we get our
information directly from the pipeline
on X now now what happens if a says for
any for whatever the amount of time was
you cannot search for Taylor Swift was
there a video circulating of Taylor
Swift accepting money from George Soros
I don't mean that literally I'm making a
joke but like what would if if someone
said I got the scoop I have the proof
right here Taylor Swift accepting money
can't and they post it nobody can find
it yeah this is like the deranged
evolution of the Barbera strand effect
what happened with the photos of her
house back in the day you take something
away makes want to go look at and this
is like a terrible thing to want to go
look up but I'm I guarantee you it only
made people look it up more uh but yeah
I see that point it's almost like
they're Hunter bidening the the hunter
Biden laptop story to the Taylor Swift
story now um so newx is just like old
Twitter in some regard is that
disappointing did you yeah I wasn't not
surprised though I've seen a lot of
things that this new company does that
are similar to the old one you know I
like it it's it's more fun but uh I
don't the images are terrible I wish
they'd get rid of all the Nancy Pelosi
nude AI photos honestly as well cuz they
are damaging my soul and people they
keep popping up in my feet I'm like why
he's not searching for them he swears
yeah imagine I really need that Pelosi
cleavage uh they're going to clip that
oh man great didn't I see today that
Elon his reaction to this was they're
going to add up another hundred
employees just to monitor content no I
saw this yeah today oh oh that makes me
so nervous we have we have a super chat
from Trump uh Trump one he says look at
Benny Johnson's X Soros owns her enti
music catalog I'm going to break this
down for you and help you understand
exactly what's going on and why Taylor
Swift is your greatest opportunity
conservatives don't waste it Benny
Johnson posts flashback Taylor Swift let
me play the clip for you it's 15 seconds
and you can listen to Taylor in her own
words I had the chance to purchase my
music I had the chance to purchase my
music outright my entire catalog was
sold to scooter Bron's Ithaca Holdings
in a deal that I'm told was funded by
the Soros family 23 capital and the
Carlile group
what does that mean these people who
believe that she's a Democrat scop think
she is now sold to soros's family or or
funded to sold to someone by that and
that she now has to work for them no no
no Taylor Swift publicly slammed the
Soros family on numerous occasions for
stealing her music they basically outbid
her for the rights to her own song to
her own Master recordings she got mad
because the the amount they were trying
to spend in the songs was not actually
worth what the songs could generate so
she was losing all of the work she had
did for years she again publicly slams
them then says I'm I own the artistic
composition but they bought the Masters
I will re-record all of my music to syn
soros's $300 million investment one of
the most epic smackdowns of the Soros
family let me stress it was something
like $300 million and by her going out
and re-recording the Masters she ripped
that investment from them to Z zero
while publicly calling them out the
opportunity here for anybody who
actually looked in this and paying
attention is you've got an army of
teenage girls who love Taylor and when
she slams Soros you go to them and like
if you're a kadad and your daughter
loves Taylor Swift you can go to go to
your daughter and say what happened did
you what was Taylor Swift talking about
with with the Soros family taking her
music from her and and they're going to
be like yeah because they wanted to try
and make money off it and then Taylor
had to record everything and then you as
the dead can connect with your daughter
and go that's dirty they why would they
do that to Taylor man those Soros people
sure are bad and there you go this is
the argument that people are making
right now like all see these posts from
dads being like I saw this video of this
dad with like his young girls like maybe
like you know two five and seven or
something and they're all cheering
watching the Super Bowl or the Chiefs
game because Taylor Swift is there and
they're like wow so exciting Taylor
Swift is organically driving women to
like bond with their dads and to get
into football whatever else like
conservative dads could do this too they
could use George showers they could talk
talk about these things they'd probably
be pretty interesting conversations
about copyright law and like
intellectual property they're just at
the for whatever reason deciding like no
we can't talk about this because Taylor
Swift endorsed Joe Biden one time she
she endorsed Joe Biden she's in the
documentary saying she's a Democrat all
that stuff of course Hollywood is this
is what they do big donors big companies
they go to celebrities and they say
you're on our side or else in this
instance they ripped her off they they
they bought her music out from
underneath her in a in a dirty move and
she her statement was something like I
hope it was worth it because two things
the amount of money they bought the
music for it the music recordings would
not generate that much money so she
couldn't pay it she's like I'd have to
spend a third of my net worth to buy the
rights to my music and I would never
make that money back but she then
re-recorded everything re re-released
those albums and now no one will ever
care about whatever the Soros family
bought so you can criticize her for
being a Democrat all day and night but I
am flabbergasted by the conservatives
who keep pushing the fake narrative the
lie I don't get it I seriously someone
spelled out for me why they keep lying
and trying to make it seem like she's
working for George Soros i i i i i
there's nothing I don't get it I can't I
can't answer that question but I mean
notwithstanding the um uh the loss of
opportunity that conservatives or
Republicans had uh by by what she did by
coming out against sorce speaking ill of
him it doesn't matter timately at the
end of the day another oligarch was
going to buy her music anyway because
the mob has always owned the music
industry and ultimately they own the
contract I'm sorry this is the scup like
guys if there's a scup the scup is sock
puppet accounts on social media posting
things like this George Soros with
Taylor Swift on puppet strings I get it
it's actually not a completely unfair
thing but how can you guarantee to sever
any opportunity someone had to actually
have a celebrity on your side it's them
this I I this is so backwards Taylor
Swift publicly criticizes Soros on
numerous occasions and for some reason
the entire wave of social media posts
from the right is that she's working for
him I'm like that's a SC up right there
I don't know who's doing it or what but
I I'm sorry if I'm going to believe a
conspiracy theory it's that deep State
whoever or whatever it is you guys think
we're like oh no oh no Taylor Swift came
out against George Soros we need control
of this quick pretend to be Maga and
claim she's for Soros and and it worked
okay but I also have like five layers of
tinfoil hats on at all times and I can
be like well Soros told her you got to
come out publicly against me so then
people don't don't buy the S I would
agree with that if the narrative was she
was against Soros right but it's not all
these conservatives just keep hammering
that claim over and over again and I'm
like that's weird because imagine if
conservatives dads were able to go to
their daughters and say I I agree with
you I support you I can't believe they
would do this to Taylor Swift and now
you're going to have a dad so here's
what happens these these teenage girls
are watching the Super Bowl and the dad
is sitting there going she works for
George Soros and the girls are going uh
Dad she hates Soros no she works for him
creating a divide between the
conservative dads and their daughters
cuz the dads believe something that's
wrong and I don't know why people keep
pushing it and then they don't have
children and also our birth our teenage
pregnancies go up and it ruins
everything conservative dads this is
your moment come on it's almost like Q
fractured into a billion different
conspiracy theories and now people are
just everything's a conspiracy which I
understand because lots of things are
conspiracy theories and the government
does really dark derange things all the
time secretly um but yeah this doesn't
feel that it's just we have we're such a
low trust Society right you can't trust
anything that comes out we can't even
look at Taylor Swift dating like the
hunky football player and be like wow
good for her but it's also anything that
comes out of Hollywood I distrust yeah I
think you made a good point about her
being 34 like here here's a conspiracy
theory for you Taylor Swift is about to
hit the wall
well also what else is she going to do
right like she is already the highest
paid female musician she was one of the
youngest people to win all kinds of
accolades like where does she go from
here the thing that she doesn't have in
her life is a I mean she has like a
family like a mom and a dad or whatever
but like she doesn't have her own kids
her best friend is Blake Lively who has
four kids I think with Ryan Reynolds
like you guys I you're all men you don't
understand this I don't even know who
these people are this is the thing
Lively 100ed R Reynolds I know Ron
Reynolds his wife they have lots of kids
together so they'll adopt Taylor no she
I think she is like one of their I don't
know I don't know whatever but like the
thing is I think she's one of their like
God Parents or something but like I
think ultimately Taylor Swift is so
interesting to me because she represents
this this thing that all women were
supposed to do which is to rise the top
and to be mad at men because they take
their career away even though they're
clearly succeeding where men could never
succeed I'm sorry there's just no male
pop star that has this kind of attention
over female f fans and yet ultimately
she gets out of this six-year
relationship she's singing constantly
about wanting to start a family and get
married and now she's with this other
guy who's been on his podcast saying yes
I want to be married he does his podcast
with his brother who's happily married
to like his college sweetheart with
multiple children like this is the rise
of a pronatalist pro- family movement
and conservatives just need to embrace
it stop making everything bad steal it
or steal it steal co-opt it come on
exactly if if if the truth is that
Taylor Swift is a big scop and she's
like going to go democr whatever the
narrative from the right needs to be to
take control of the river that that
massive Force coming at you and divert
it by instead of attacking the things
she does with Democrats support the
things she's doing like I love that
Taylor says she wants to have a family
she's right and Travis saying the same
thing how wholesome I I actually am
really inspired she doesn't like George
SOS what a good person make that the
focal point right also I've been
thinking I'm not a fan of hers I can
appreciate some songs but like the work
ethic that went into re-recording
everything is crazy like didn't Michael
Jackson buy all the Beatles music that's
the last time I cared about who bought
whose catalog was when Jackson bought
all of the be can you tell that story
really quick isn't like McCartney didn't
McCartney tell Jackson you should own
catalog music catalog and then yes
Jackson turned around and bought the
Beet he actually he actually outbid
McCartney for his own songs but but but
see here's the difference between what
we're talking about now and then there
was no politics involved in that at all
now everything is shaded by politics
totally we can't get away from it nope
man it's just it's just Taylor Swift
pulled off what may be one of the
biggest Fus to the Soros family ever
they bought music for for something I I
think it was three can you fact check me
on this I think it was $300 million and
then by her re-recording it all she
ripped $300 million out of their pockets
man that's because she their their
investment becomes zero so they bought
the Masters not the publishing so she
owns the artist composition right which
means the song core the the the
recordings she did were bought by Soros
and the car group and these other
investors by re-recording it that
investment was worthless now right just
absolutely worthless and he sold it for
close it's never been disclosed but they
believe it's north of $300 million by he
you mean scooter BR scooter Bron to yep
and she was saying something like it's
not worth it imagine all those songs on
streaming platforms how much money will
it generate nowhere near that much in
their lifetime that means she would have
to in like it it it may have been that
they knew Taylor wanted her career this
is her her life's work and they were
probably thinking like you're a
billionaire if you want it we're going
to drive the price up to 300 million
you'll never make that money back it's
ours was she smart enough to realize it
wasn't worth it yes and then she said no
okay well now and here's the thing maybe
that converting Swifty phant this may
have been the move to try and control
her basically you're a high-profile
celebrity you work for us now or we will
own your life's work and you can do
nothing about it instead she goes I will
re-record every single song and you will
get nothing thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net